30 Bier
schraube ich mir heute rein
ich laufe einfach den Leuten nach
Digger das spielt eine Klavier
[Musik]
wir alle wisst ist die Queen ja leider
verstorben wir haben allerdings bereits
den neuen König entdeckt
5 Sekunden später
wie kann das denn zweimal abgeben
Alter hör auf
nicht umsonst ne außer der Tod aber
nicht mehr der Tod ist umsonst kostet
sich dein Leben
du fragst mich richtig ab ne
Weihnachtssachen schon Bruder wir
fliegen nach Mallorca 35°c
hast du Spieler ich habe Stadien
Spiegel weitergeleitet
aber dicker wir fliegen nur kennst diese
Leute die so in Privatjet fliegen dann
sagen wieso hey schreib mal schon mal
vorher aus Film so cool welche rausgehen
dass sie nicht in Kamera gucken
weil es so einmal im Jahr außer man
fliegt halt mehrmals hin dann ist halt
auch
öfter hierhin
wir drehen noch immer keine Doku kannst
ausmachen
ich glaube ich muss Flugzeug verlassen
es könnte nicht zwei Maschinen
gleichzeitig abheben
hallo
gar nicht will
kai ist das okay für dich
strahle auf Malle
das ist übrigens der Mann hinter der
Kamera
ja müssen wir jetzt nicht mehr darüber
reden es gibt so zwei drei
aber wo ist der Bus also der Bus mit den
Leuten ist interessiert weiß ich nicht
größer als ganz bielefeld
es gibt auf diesem Schiff E-Scooter
ja wohin auf die 8 Kabinen 8 das habt
ihr für eine Kabine
[Musik]
Station
vielen Dank
ich habe so viel Arschloch Wasser
hallo ach Humor du Weisheit des Tages
Proben
seid ihr eher Proben oder kontrabent
oder
seit sechs Stunden am Schnitt ich muss
hier drei Stunden mal Videomaterial
unterschreiben bei der alles irgendwie
Film der USA
ihr fragt euch
Luca
warum bist du angezogen den Pinguin
[Musik]
wir haben gerade einfach zwei
Mitarbeiter kennengelernt von der AIDA
und wir haben uns jetzt gesagt dass wir
übermorgen recht sehr gerne sehr
herzlich gerne Sprachen lernen
babbelig abgeben nee danke mein
Lieblings-DJ tritt gerade auf
[Musik]
ich muss jetzt leider sagen ich habe
heute leider kein Foto für dich
es ist 5 Uhr Mann ich komme gerade vom
Feiern und der Typ
der schläft
no joke Leute es ist 17:35 Uhr und das
Video was ihr jetzt gerade hier seht
soll in 25 Minuten online gehen ich
glaube ich habe noch nie so kurz vorher
was mit meinem Handy aufgenommen bevor
es dann auf YouTube online gegangen ist
allerdings würde ich an dieser Stelle
jetzt glaube ich den heutigen Vlog auch
beenden ich habe noch so viele Dateien
von der AIDA so dass ich das glaube ich
in zwei Part splitten werde also
irgendwann die Tage kommt dann part 2
von unserer Kreuzfahrt usef hat einfach
unfassbar viel gefilmt ich hätte auch in
dieses Video hier noch viel mehr ich
zeige euch mal ein paar Sachen User bei
mir so gefilmt hat nebenbei
[Musik]
danke für 100 GB Videomaterial
von denen ich 99 Gigabyte in den
Papierkorb stecken werde